tous nous avons en commun d'avoir été
petit et d'avoir été bercée par les
mêmes conte de fées
et puis tous nous avons grandi eu accès
à d'autres récits et nous avons oublié
peut un peu ceux de notre enfance
moi pendant trente ans de ma vie j'étais
obsédé pas une histoire un conte
d'andersen le vilain petit canard
vous vous souvenez ce petit canard qui
est différent des autres et qui est
rejeté par les siens et qui après mille
épreuves découvre qu'il est en fait un
signe et qui se sent enfin comme tout le
monde
pendant des années je me suis demandée
avec anxiété
est-ce que moi aussi j'aurais un jour la
chance de découvrir
qu'il existe une espèce à laquelle
j'appartiens
mon histoire commence dans les années 60
dans un quartier populaire de paris au
fond d'une impasse
ma mère est orpheline depuis l'âge de 13
ans et elle n'a que 17 ans quand
j'arrive dans sa vie
nous sommes élevés toutes les deux par
sa grande soeur m'attends donc que je
considère comme un secondaire
d'ailleurs toute ma vie je parlerai de
mes deux mamans
mon père est beaucoup moins gentil qu
mes deux mamans il est trés coléreux et
j'ai l'impression qu'ils ne m'aiment pas
alors je voudrais vous présenter ma
famille ici vous allez voir ma mère et
ma petite soeur
et puis mon père est la tante dont je
vous parlais
et là
c'est moi
alors comme vous pouvez le remarquer sur
ces vieilles photos je ne leur ressemble
pas du tout
je m'aperçois très vite que ma peau est
plus foncée que celle de mes parents
mais ma mère m'a fait comprendre très
vite que je n'avais pas été adopté
alors dans ma tête d'enfant
si je ne ressemble pas à mes parents et
à ma soeur c'est que je ne suis pas
normal
et ça se confirme parce qu'on petites
sections dans la cour on me maltraites
en brutally je suis la seule enfant de
couleur et on m'appelle la négresse
je me sens tellement mal qu'à trois ans
et demi je ne mange presque plus
tant et si bien que la direction
d'établissement demande à ma mère de me
changer d'école
ma nouvelle école est très particulière
il y a une petite fille qui boite il y
en a une qui arrivent d'un pays en
guerre une autre qui dit rien et puis
qui se balance d'avant en arrière
nous sommes toutes des vilains petits
canards dans cette école
alors je me sens en sécurité
est alors résultats scolaires deviennent
excellent et en sixième j'accède à un
collège normal
et là je me dis que je vais peut-être
enfin être comme les autres
mais dans ce collège on ne m'appelle
plus la négresse mais le perroquet
alors vous allez me dire passer de
vilains canards à perroquet c'est quand
même une promotion
mais je le prends pas étonnamment comme
ça alors pourquoi le perroquet parce
qu'on n'a pas appris à m'habiller alors
je mélange toutes les couleurs les
rayures les points le jaune pétard le
rouge et puis ma mère ne sait pas
coiffer les cheveux frisés alors elle me
les coupe très court et on prend pour un
garçon une fois un petit garçon à qui on
demande de me donner la main il s'écrit
ah non
elle est trop moche je me dis qu'il doit
être vilaine mais que au moins il a
repéré que j'étais une fille se sent
progrès
alors au lycée en seconde je prends une
grande décision je demande de l'aide je
demande à mes camarades de classe de
m'expliquer comment il faut choisir ses
vêtements quels sont les tenues qu'il
faut porter comment on prend soin de soi
quels sont les musiques il faut écouter
et surprise tout ce que je sollicite me
vienne en aide alors je les imitent
autant que je peux et à la proche du bac
j'ai une camarade de classe qui remplit
un dossier pour une école de commerce je
n'ai aucune idée de ce qu'est une école
de commerce mais je suis rempli le même
dossier et je suis en prépa puis en
école de commerce
et là je fais comme les autres boursiers
je fais des tas de petits boulots et il
ya un job un job d'été qui fait rêver
toutes les autres filles de l'école ses
hôtesses de l'air saisonnière sur air
france
ça me parait mais inaccessible parce que
les hôtesses de l'air elles sont très
belles et à l'époque elles sont plutôt
très blanche
mais je postule et la chance me sourit
je suis prise
et je me souviens quand je monte dans
l'avion pour la première fois à fait mon
hôtel avec mon mon uniforme de paix ce
qui ressemble à celui des autres
hôtesses je m'écris devant
l'équipage complètement médusé ça y est
je suis un signe
je me sens enfin joly à cette époque là
et c'est à 20 ans à peu près que
j'apprends
que mon père n'est pas mon père
alors vous allez me dire vu les photos
elle n'est pas super perspicace
elle aurait peut-être pu s'en douter un
peu
c'est vrai mais c'est quand même un
énorme choc
en fait avant de rencontrer son mari
celui qu on m'a toujours présenté comme
mon père ma mère a eu une aventure avec
un monsieur antillais marié dans la
famille était en martinique la mère se
retrouve enceinte et le monsieur est
bien embêté alors il lui suggère d'aller
en angleterre se faire avorter
elle n'a pas d'argent et lui non plus
alors lui il va voir sa grand mère et il
lui demande de lui prêter la somme sous
prétexte qu'il a envie d'un beau poste
de radio
sauf que là gentil grand-mère le
lendemain elle ne donne pas le l'argent
dont il a besoin elle lui offre
un magnifique poste de radio
certains d'entre vous ont peut-être été
conçu sur des très belles chansons moi
je suis ici grâce
ni fiq poste de radio
maintenant que je me sens jolie je suis
réconcilié avec ma couleur de peau
mais si cette fois ci je veux absolument
ressembler aux autres c'est au niveau du
statut social je veux ressembler à ce
que j'ai fréquentés en école de commerce
alors avec mon diplôme je postule pour
un poste qui gagnent de l'argent je
deviens pas ultra riches mais plus que
mes parents et là je fais comme pretty
woman je copie la façon dont il faut se
tenir à table pendant les des jeux
d'affaires je m'inscris dans les cours
de gym en vogue je prends des cours de
ski et des cours d'équitation
j'imite mes nouveaux collègues et j'y
parviens parfaitement
je fais maintenant partie de ce milieu
qui n'est pas le mien
je me dis que j'ai tous les ingrédients
pour avoir confiance en moi je me sens
joly j'accepte ma couleur de peau j'ai
le bon milieu social
et pourtant c'est à ce moment là que je
tombe en dépression
depuis tout petit je pensais qu'il me
fallait
ressembler aux autres pour être heureuse
or j'ai tout appris sauf le bonheur
alors tout en travaillant je reprends
des études et jeu j'étudie les sciences
du comportement et notamment les travaux
de recherche sur l'épanouissement
et je me découvre une passion pour un
nouveau métier à formation alors je
forme des personnes de plus en plus
qualifiés et puis je suis nommé à la
tête d'un grand département qui gère des
grands projets de formation je commence
à m'épanouir dans mon travail et c'est
là que je fais une rencontre qui va me
donner la clé pour être heureuse ça se
passe à la gare de lyon un jour il ya
des intempéries tels que les trains sont
annulés ou retardés
il y à un haut lieu de la grogne
habituel des éclats de rire alors je
vais voir ce qui se passe et là il ya un
agent d'accueil monté sur une estrade
improvisée il harangue la foule qui a le
plus de retard est ce que c'est vous les
lyonnais
et les lyonnais hurle 40 minutes
quarante minutes
les marseillais c'est votre dernier mot
alamar secure
marseille 50 minutes 50 minutes et au
fond on entend des voix qui s'élèvent
belfort on a gagné home est annulé on
est annulé
il met le feu la guerre de lyon
alors j'attends qu'il soit seul
et puis je vais l'aborder et je lui dis
mais comment vous faites pour faire
sourire des personnes quand les trains
sont annulés et il me dit avec un
sourire c'est simple quand je me lève le
matin j'ai qu'une seule idée en tête
pourvu que j'arrive à faire sourire au
moins une personne dans ma journée et
vous voyez les gens en soirée et il
poursuit au début j'avais du mal je
faisais sourire une à deux personnes par
jour puis après je suis passé à des
groupes puis maintenant je fais sourire
des foules
cet agent d'accueil les exactement comme
tous les autres agents d'accueil il a le
même uniforme elle a le même métier mais
là quelque chose en lui qui le rend
complètement unique qu'il a travaillé
développer il a une sorte de talent une
signature
il se définit comme un fabricant de
souris rhin et je sens bien que lui il
est heureux
alors j'ai approfondi mes recherches je
travaille pendant des années et je
finalise une démarche qui permet de
découvrir son talent signature
le talent signature c'est le type précis
d'activité qui vous permet de vibrer et
d'exceller c'est le type précis
d'activité dans like dans lequel vous
excellez qui vous fait vibrer
quand vous le découvrez vous pouvez
évidemment le développer le cultiver et
l'utiliser dans votre vie
professionnelle mais aussi dans votre
vie personnelle
le talent signature ça donne plus de
sens et aussi plus de lumière à votre
quotidien
alors
quand j'ai finalisé la démarche eh bien
je l'utilisent avec des grands groupes
comme aujourd'hui et je démarre toujours
en posant trois questions
première question
si vous analysez votre passé qu'elles
sont dans toutes les activités que vous
avez pu faire celles dans lesquelles
vous avez le sentiment d'être le plus
compétent ou la plus compétente et celle
qui vous a apporté le plus de plaisir en
même temps compétences plus plaisir
deuxième question quand ce que vous
faites aujourd'hui
professionnellement ou hors
professionnels
quelles sont les activités les tâches
les missions dans lesquelles vous avez
le sentiment d'exceller
et qui vous font vibrer qui vous font
battre le coeur
troisième question
imaginons que je vous donne à chacun et
chacune d'entre vous 100 millions
d'euros coup d'argent
mais il ya une condition
vous devez
exercer un métier celui que vous voulez
quel est le métier vous exercerez y est
et pourquoi
alors quand on analyse la réponse à ces
trois questions on est sur la bonne voie
pour découvrir votre talent signature
et c'est lors d'un séminaire
que je me fais cette réflexion et je me
dis mais finalement l'histoire du vilain
petit canard main induite en erreur
c'est vrai ressembler aux autres
ça paraît une excellente idée qui
d'entre vous n'a jamais voulu avoir le
même physique que la même confiance en
soi ou le même niveau de vie que les
autres moi c'est un véritable moteur que
de vouloir ressembler aux autres ça m'a
permis de me dépasser dans tous les sens
du terme jusque là l'histoire de petit
canard elle est juste mais après il
manque l'essentiel
est gelée compris quand j'ai rencontré
un grand généticiens qui travaillent sur
le génome humain
il me dit est ce que vous savez que
votre empreinte digitale et unique même
des vrais jumeaux n'ont pas la même
empreinte digitale
mais ajoutent-ils
en décodant génome humain on s'est
aperçu que votre empreinte digitale n'a
jamais existé jamais et encore plus fort
elle n'existera plus jamais vous êtes
une personne complètement unique dans
toute l'histoire de l'humanité
et c'était ça la pièce qui manquait pour
donner du sens à mon histoire l'histoire
d'une petite fille qui toute sa vie
voulais ressembler aux autres qui finit
par y arriver
mais qui réalise que ce qui lui faut
finalement cultiver développer si son
propre talent sa propre signature
autrement dit quand on croyait être un
canard découvrir qu'on est un signe
c'est pas une fin en soi c'est juste un
début
alors
si je suis ici aujourd'hui c'est d'abord
pour rendre hommage à mes deux mamans à
qui je dédie cette conférence mais c'est
aussi pour vous dire que vous êtes
chacune et chacun d'entre vous unique
vous êtes tous et toutes peuvent porter
de talents qui ne demandent qu'à être
développé et que vous soyez
conférencière formatrice auteurs comme
moi ou agents d'accueil gare de lyon
vous pouvez
faire une différence laisser une
empreinte vous pouvez même peut-être
changer des vies et vous devez avoir
confiance en vous et vous devez le faire
parce que ce que vous pouvez apporter au
monde personne d'autres que vous ne
pourra jamais la porte et
merci
[Applaudissements]